you now have a pretty good idea of how
to start working on a new project but
what's the best way to learn new skills
aside from just practice practice
practice
I think Jacques has some ideas but again
he went back to work so we need to bug
him again yeah so um I actually wanted
to just mention the awesomeness that is
learning HTML and CSS on the web when
you can see it every day so if you like
something in a webpage and you want to
see how they did it you can pop open dev
tools and actually see how we cut it up
so if you like something on Udacity
website you want to use that motif or
that design those type of styles you can
see what we did and that's really great
and not something you can do in a lot of
other environments so in terms of
learning it's a great place to start
because I mean that's how I started I
was looking at how other people did how
other people coded up their solutions
how they managed to make something look
a certain way and being able to open it
up and our dev tools are much better now
and they will really allow you to dive
into how somebody put something together
so go and check out a website that you
find interesting you'll you'll be amazed
that sort of what people have done and
you cannot learn a tremendous amount
from it